[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
politique à table sur LCP l'émission on
parle cuisine alimentation agriculture
écologique mais aussi un peu politique
et cette semaine nous recevons philippe
Juvin bonjour bonjour et bienvenue et
avec moi pour présenter cette émission
Jean-Pierre Montana bonjour Jean-Pierre
bonjour Brigitte bonjour Philippe juin
vous êtes député les républicains des
Hauts-de-Seine urgentistes de profession
adeptes du cumul des mandats vous
exercez toujours et occupez le poste de
chef de service à l'hôpital Georges
Pompidou à Paris depuis 2012 vous avez
toujours été un médecin engagé
politiquement à droite en tant que
conseiller régional d'Île-de-France
député européen ou maire de La
Garenne-Colombes engagé aussi en
Afghanistan en Ukraine ou lors des
attentats de 2015 à Paris vous avez été
candidat à la primaire des républicains
pour l'élection présidentielle de 2022
vous réalisez un score de 3,1% certes
décevant mais pas si loin du score de
votre candidate vous aussi vous avez été
vict du vote utile
ultra médaillé les jugandonneurs
méritent Palmes Académiques je comprends
que vous militiez pour les 39 heures et
la retraite à 65 ans mais Jean-Pierre
une vie comme ça est-ce que ça laisse du
temps pour la table pas vraiment car
c'est une assiette digne d'un relais
routier que l'on va avaler des frites
aux yeux brouillés et en dessert des
fruits dans le dessous des plats les
pesticides à l'origine du cancer de la
prostate reportage près de Rennes chez
Christian jour et dans les pieds dans
plat comment redonner l'appétit aux
malades qui l'ont perdu à cause de
traitement lourds un défi lancé par un
chef étoilé lyonnais reportage à suivre
allez on passe à table tout de suite
cuisine et confidence
à Philippe Juvin quand j'ai su que vous
alliez venir je me suis dit on ne va pas
échapper au repas bien-être avec du
brocoli réputé pour ses vertus en qui
sont anticancéreuses et pourquoi pas du
maquereau Brigitte bourré d'oméga 3
excellent pour le cœur et bien non pas
du tout au menu frites et œufs brouillés
oups petit choc alors c'est donc
l'hôpital qui se fout de la santé
Brigitte des frites pleines de mauvaises
grains et des œufs qui donneraient du
cholestérol non c'est pas si simple
d'abord philippe Juvin vous n'êtes pas
diététicien ni nutritionniste pas du
tout urgentiste nuance donc pour faire
simple dans l'urgence 24 heures sur 24
même au moment de passer à table entre
les brancards qui congestionnent les
couloirs du service et là on comprend
mieux quelques frites gourmandes et
addictives bienvenue petit plaisir pour
faire oublier la grande misère de
l'hôpital et des œufs pour les protéines
car les journées sont longues et enfin
un peu de salade pour se donner bonne
conscience devant des malades et je fais
le bon diagnostic professeur presque
presque non mais c'est vrai que c'est un
métier très exigeant et il y a une chose
que j'ai apprise à l'armée c'est que
pour que l'armée fonctionne bien comme
ce sont des métiers durs et c'est un peu
pareil chez urgentiste il faut que les
repas soient roboratifs et c'est une
condition absolue du bon moral du bon
moral des troupes et puis bon on est
quand même dans une émission culino
politique et donc c'est aussi un clin
d'oeil les œufs brouillés parce que vous
savez les œufs brouillés c'était Giscard
qui quand il est élu président de la
République en 74 décide d'aller chez les
Français ils s'invite chez les Français
alors à l'époque ça paraît dingue
d'ailleurs salaire franchement et une
famille malienne je me souviens en fait
ils viennent tout je crois tous les deux
mois il est dans une famille c'est
évidemment très préparé tout ça
évidemment la question c'est qu'est-ce
qu'on lui fait au président de la
République et il avait voulu expliquer
qu'il fallait faire des choses simples
et avait dit j'adore les œufs brouillés
donc chaque fois qu'il est quelque part
ce bruit mais j'aurais pu choisir des
pommes avec Chirac en 95 vous savez
d'ailleurs vous souvenez la pomme manger
des pommes en fait d'où c'est venu c'est
venu d'une erreur c'est à dire que les
communicantes Chirac lui dessinent comme
comme symbole de sa campagne un arbre
sur lequel on voit des fruits on sait
pas trop ce que c'est lui n'est pas au
courant du tout il arrive au journal de
TF1 ou de France 2 je sais pas et le
journaliste il sort son arbre de
campagne alors Monsieur Chirac qu'est-ce
que ça représente et là Chirac découvre
l'arbre qui a été dessiné il savait pas
de quoi il s'agissait il voit ça il voit
des fruits rouges j'ai dit des pommes
mais pourquoi des pommes et dit parce
que j'aime les pommes et c'était quand
même comme ça que la campagne comme quoi
ça marche c'est pas la peine de se payer
des communicants qui coûte une fortune
vous voyez il faut simplement dire qu'on
mange des pommes alors est-ce que vous
aimez les plats plus élaborés les plats
la cuisine traditionnelle ou des plats
d'autres cultures d'ailleurs moi je suis
d'abord j'aime tout et je suis curieux
de tout mais c'est vrai que dans ma vie
quotidienne le repas et bien j'essaie de
le coincer entre deux ou trois activités
mais j'aime dans le repas peut-être plus
encore que la nourriture
le plaisir de voir de voir sa famille
ses amis
la convivialité autour de la table
même si passé au bout d'une heure je
commence à avoir des escarres aux fesses
donc je me lève mais je trouve qu'il y a
un play il y a un plaisir à un plaisir
de la discussion à table c'est le moment
où on échange on est d'accord pas
d'accord on peut manger aussi donc
politique vous passez quand même du
temps à table depuis que vous êtes
député vous faites plus de déjeuners on
m'avait dit qu'il fallait faire très
attention quand on était les députés on
risquait de grossir alors j'ai fait
attention et c'est pour ça qu'on voyait
que je vous ai demandé des frites tout
ça est très logique non simplement les
frites
c'est un concept voilà c'est un concept
mais en attendant Jean-Pierre vous avez
nous dire trois astuces sur comment on
fait les œufs brouillés oui parce qu'on
avait entendre Philippe juin on a
l'impression que les oies c'est très
facile non parce qu'en fait les œufs
brouillés c'est très compliqué d'abord
il faut choisir des œufs coques c'est à
dire pondu il y a moins de 9 jours donc
ultra frais plein air et bio c'est
encore mieux c'est le must comptez trois
œufs par personne
c'est pas mal alors deux disons si on
veut mais qu'on parlait de roboratif
donc trois battez les grossièrement avec
une fourchette dans un saladier en métal
en métal et ensuite vous faites chauffer
une casserole avec de l'eau et vous
mettez votre saladier dans l'eau parce
que les œufs brouillés ça se fait au
bain-marie si c'est pour mettre deux
œufs brouillés dans une poêle comme ça
dire tiens j'ai les yeux brouilles c'est
pas ça
oui c'est une omelette ou des œufs mal
brouillés là va tourner très longuement
ça peut prendre 10 à 15 minutes et puis
un moment ça se fige et c'est fait mais
c'est vraiment un feu très très doux et
au bain-marie donc si vous faites des
œufs brouillés le matin au brunch il
faut s'y prendre un peu à l'avance et si
jamais vous voulez ratez j'ai une astuce
vous rajoutez un peu de crème vous
retournez ni vu ni connu personne ne
verra parce qu'en fait c'est le jour et
le blanc qui est en tournant longtemps
vont donner cet aspect crémeux et non
pas de la crème fraîche rajouter parce
que quoi ça apporte dans l'eau il puisse
tenir le choc de l'eau un peu
frémissante etc mais effectivement un
plan
je dirais parce que sinon ça se fige
assez vite et si ça se fiche vite c'est
d'où mon astuce de rajouter un peu de
crème
vous Philippe je vais vous les faites
comment je vous ai demandé des ouvriers
parce que je ne sais pas les faire et
donc on en mange je n'en mange jamais
enfin mais j'adore ça et donc je me suis
dit il m'invite moi j'adore les œufs
sous toutes leurs formes d'ailleurs le
soir quand je hier on nous avions
jusqu'à minuit je suis rentré chez moi à
vers une heure du matin
je n'avais pas dîner qu'est-ce que je me
suis fait je fais des œufs alors à
minuit les œufs c'est ce sont des œufs
durs vous mettez les œufs ça bout
pendant ce temps-là vous chaude pour les
oeufs
et je vais faire refroidir par un choc
thermique je le mets dans de l'eau très
froide et je suis capable de me nourrir
de pain de fromage et de et donc quand
vous m'avez dit que voulez-vous manger
je dis bah j'ai rien demandé ce bruit
parce que je ne m'en fais jamais c'est
très bon j'ai encore mieux pour vous
quand vous rentrez vous faites votre
petite salade et vous prenez un œuf vous
mettez dans un bol avec de l'eau
micro-ondes 40 secondes et vous avez un
œuf poché c'est encore meilleur qu'un
œuf dur ah bah je savais pas ça voilà
vous cassez dans un bol plein d'eau vous
cassez votre offre 45 secondes au
micro-ondes et là vous avez un œuf poché
vous mettez sur votre petite salade
plein d'eau c'est-à-dire vous mettez de
l'eau dans le bol et vous cassez l’œuf
dans l'eau
le ratio entre remplissez votre bol
d'eau puis vous mettez votre offre
dedans j'essaierai ce soir
c'est plus gourmand qu'un
aussi donc j'essaierai ce soir bon je
vous passe un coup de fil à une heure du
matin
pas trop longtemps
comment vous vous organisez vos journées
alors encore une fois moi je suis je
suis pas un exemple d'équilibre
alimentaire le matin je ne prends pas de
petit déjeuner
rien à voir avec le jeune
alternatifs
je cours je prends un café comme
beaucoup de médecins à de spécialités
travail samedi dimanche ce jour de fête
et nocturne
je suis un adepte du café en fait je
pense que ce sont des cafés plutôt
occupationnels je suis pas certain que
ça soit indispensable pour rester
éveillé etc mais ça fait partie de
l'opérations dans les machines à café
qu'on nous vend je sais pas trop ce
qu'il y a si c'est de l'eau plutôt noir
qui a un goût de café je savais à quel
pourcentage en tout cas c'est plutôt
occupationnel et puis alors à midi
parfois je déjeune un peu comme
aujourd'hui c'est à dire
voilà et puis il m'arrive de faire un
repas quand je ne suis pas en séance le
soir mais est-ce que l'aspect santé
conditionne vos menus est-ce que vous
dites attention je peux pas
j'essaye est-ce que ça passe au tamis de
cette grille de la santé alors j'essaye
depuis un an par exemple là c'est
vraiment formidable depuis un an depuis
un an plus de Nutella j'adorais ça
depuis un an plus de soda plus et depuis
un an plus de sucre ajouté dans
un déclic
je me suis dit qu'il fallait que je
fasse quelque chose je vous dis pas que
c'est mauvais pour la santé que les
sodas
alors ce qui est mauvais pour la santé
là c'est le médecin qui parle il y a
beaucoup de choses mauvaise pour la
santé mais il y a aussi des choses
bonnes les choses mauvaises pour la
santé c'est ce qu'on appelle les
aliments
ultra transformés vous savez il y a des
aliments sont classés en quatre
catégories il y a une classification
Nova je crois que c'est comme ça que ça
s'appelle international catégorie 1
l'aliment non transformé l'orange la
tomate catégorie 4 l'aliment ultra
transformé
les lasagnes industrielles absolument ou
le ketchup
pendant des années on a dit c'est
probablement mauvais pour la santé le
problème de l'affirmation mais on en
parlera peut-être de ces bons pour la
santé ou c'est mauvais
c'est la preuve quelle est la preuve
scientifique de ce qu'on avance il y a
un travail qui a été publié récemment
qui est très intéressant parce que c'est
le premier qui massivement apporte des
arguments en faveur de la nécessité
d'une alimentation de bon niveau c'est
une étude faite sur plusieurs centaines
de milliers de personnes sur 25 ans donc
vous voyez une vraie étude très long
terme je rappelle une étude de corps et
qui montre que ceux qui se nourrissent
principalement de d'aliments de 4e
catégorie donc très transformé en fait
ce que vous mangez à la cantine en fait
ça c'est simple y compris à l'hôpital
probablement et bien vous avez 23% de
risque d'augmentation du cancer du côlon
le colon c'est le tube digestif pourquoi
vous pouvez imaginer que dans des
aliments très transformés tout n'est pas
totalement naturel et donc ça crée d'une
manière chronique au long cours une
inflammation de la lumière c'est-à-dire
l'intérieur du tube digestif et cette
inflammation il y a un moment où
certaines de ces cellules du côlon
deviennent
inflammatoire deviennent
et en particulier des cancers d'organes
qui filtrent quand vous quand vous
respirez il y a le poumon qui filtre
quand vous mangez il y a le le foie qui
filtre et les voies biliaires qui
filtrent le pancréas qui filtre les
reins qui filtrent votre alimentation et
votre et vos boissons et moi il y a des
cancers quand j'ai fait mes études de
médecine maintenant il y a une trentaine
d'années dont on parlait quasiment pas
par exemple le cancer des voies
biliaires c'était un cancer exceptionnel
c'était dans les livres aujourd'hui on
envoie donc là il y aura une corrélation
immédiate avec moi encore une fois il y
a aucune preuve scientifique je veux
vraiment que les choses soient claires
je mais je ne peux pas m'empêcher de
faire certaines réflexion que qu'est-ce
qui a changé entre-temps est-ce que
c'est l'environnement est-ce que c'est
l'alimentation est-ce que c'est notre
mode de vie est-ce que les gens vivant
plus longtemps peut-être que du coup ils
ont plus le temps de déclarer des
cancers il y a c'est ça les facteurs
confondants
c'en était mais là on en voit plus
peut-être que les pistes aujourd'hui
alors qu'on les voyait pas mais alors ce
qui est sûr c'est que il y a
alimentation il faut faire attention
mais d'abord il faut manger pour vivre
c'est difficile mais il y a des trucs
qu'il faut absolument éviter évidemment
c'est la colle par exemple ça c'est bien
alors là alors ça c'est culturelle
c'est beau c'est mauvais pour la santé
c'est un problème de c'est un problème
de de concentration et de mais ce qui
est certain c'est que l'alcoolisme donc
là avec ça nous sommes pas alcooliques
mais l'alcoolisme et le tabagisme c'est
une évidence tout le monde le sait mais
je le répète parce que quand vous
demandez aux Français quels sont les
facteurs d'environnement dans votre
environnement qui nuise à votre santé et
bien ils oublient majoritairement de
parler du tabac et comme si c'était
ouais bon alors que le tabac
exactement et il y a des cancers et puis
il y a une grande nouveauté c'est qu'on
découvre
qu'une partie importante des cancers à
l'OMS dit 10 20% ça dépend des unes 10%
de tous les cancers sont liés à
l'environnement quand même et en
particulier à des maladies infectieuses
vous avez vous attraper un virus vous
avez vous pouvez vous avez vous êtes à
risque d'un cancer 10 20 30 ans plus
tard et ça c'est nouveau parce que vous
comprenez bien que si une maladie
infectieuse donne un cancer ça ouvre des
voies considérables dans la prévention
de ces cancers puisque c'est un agent
infectieux qui arrive de l'extérieur et
et ça il faut l'avoir en tête c'est
peut-être quelque chose c'est une voix
pour l'avenir qui est évidemment
importante un mot de ce vin qui est
Corse donc de couleur rouge là mais il
pourrait être blanc aussi l'appellation
c'est certaine contrôlée il y a cinq
appellations en Corse et ça en fait
partie c'est du 100% ce qui a carré
l'eau qui est un des un des cépages
qu'on trouve là-bas élevage 9 mois en
food 9 mois en cuve et sa spécificité
des notes de du coup j'ai des épices
vous nous avez demandé donc un vin Corse
pour quelle raison pour des raisons
identitaires on va dire ça comme ça
moi ma mère ma mère est Corse était
Corse et je viens d'un village qui est
situé au nord d'Ajaccio dans la montagne
un village quelques centaines
d'habitants uchians eu de ciami Ethan
c'est l'endroit où j'ai passé toutes mes
vacances d'enfants c'est l'endroit où il
y a la maison de ma mère c'est l'endroit
où j'ai moi-même ma maison c'est un
village
non je suis passé c'est probablement le
plus beau village bien entendu mais
c'est un village des racines et où j'ai
l'impression quand j'y vais que le temps
s'est arrêté c'est ça qui est
extraordinaire c'est à dire qu'il y a 30
ans
le clocher faisait le même bruit au même
heure et la montagne était toujours là
et donc j'ai cette impression de
permanente quand je suis là-bas qui fait
que je suis très attaché à cet endroit
donc c'était un clin d'oeil le vacance
je me suis dit il faut quand même que
j'arrive à parler de la Corse comment on
va faire je ne vais pas leur demander de
faire venir Bruce du Saint-Georges et du
Saint-Georges
ou de l'eau de Lorette mais ou du
fromage mais les fromages corses il faut
savoir les apprécier donc j'ai pris
aucun risque et je suis passé
souvent là alors il est très doux je
trouve qu'il est très doux très très se
battre avec les autres
ils sont plutôt tanniques les vins
corses non il y en a en fait il y a
quatre régions encore c'est donc il y a
des sols différents et donc on trouve un
petit peu de tout d'accord
charcuterie corse est quelque chose
assez extraordinaire et voyez-vous
nous les Français nous sommes tous
attachés à des racines et des racines
même quand vous êtes parisien vous êtes
attachés à des racines et moi mes
racines sont là-bas et
quand vous avez dit que vous avez
rappelé mon score extraordinaire la
première de la droite et vous avez
raison
c'est pas du tout un mauvais d'abord
j'ai fait 10 fois plus que Bruno Le
Maire donc je vous dis à la primaire
donc on peut voir les choses comme ça je
vois c'est comme ça non mais je
plaisante j'apprécie beaucoup Bruno Le
Maire simplement j'avais profité de
cette prière de la droite pour chaque
fois parler de la Corse parce que je
pense qu'il y a des spécificités liées à
l'insularité qui doivent être prises en
compte dans les politiques publiques et
je vais bientôt encore dans quelques
semaines et je réflé a signé un texte
pour c'est pas l'alimentation mais c'est
de la santé je pense très important
d'avoir un centre hospitalo
universitaire en Corse ce qu'il n'y a
pas au moins pour une raison principale
c'est que quand vous êtes un jeune
lycéen Corse voulait faire de la
médecine et bien rapidement vous devez
partir sur le continent et souvent les
gens ne reviennent pas parce qu'ils
organisent leur vie et probablement
il y a des airs médicaux partout en
France mais c'est vrai il y a une
caractère insulaire particulier et je
pense à indispensable d'avoir un CHU en
Corse après il y aura une petite
question entre Ajaccio et Bastia mais je
vais pas rentrer dans des détails
vraiment incollable et on va passer au
quiz à présent
alors Philippe Juvet en tant que médecin
vous êtes tenu par le fameux serment
d'Hippocrate mais seriez-vous nous dire
ce qu'est l'Hippocrate dans
l'alimentation alors j'ai plusieurs
propositions à vous faire quand même ah
c'est une tisane du Moyen-Âge à base de
verveine et de tilleuls B c'est un
élixir fabriqué à partir de sauge et de
feuilles d'ortie mixées c'est c'est un
vin dans lequel masseur gingembre
cannelle et sucre et d c'est un hectare
confectionné à partir des raisins
impropres à la vinification
alors j'en ai aucune idée mais alors
Hippocrate c'est h y donc en grec ça
vient de U
upsilon
est-ce que ça m'avance
je parierai pour un pour quelque chose
avec du vin mais c'est
bien oui au 16e siècle cette boisson
était recommandée pour lutter par est-il
contre ce vers vivant qui s'attaquait au
cœur il fallait boire de l'Hippocrate
faire du grec ancien
je rappelle que c'est comme ça aussi que
dans dans l'Odyssée
Ulysse arrive à se sortir des rêtres du
cyclope en faisant boire Polyphème
bien sûr et moi je me souviens j'ai
appris par coeur à l'époque on apprenait
par coeurs des tirades de l'Odyssée
parce que ça faisait partie de la
culture générale le col a changé alors
deuxième quiz je connais toujours les
Verts je peux vous les réciter si vous
voulez une autre fois alors figurez-vous
qu'à la Renaissance la viande de baleine
était un mais fort recherché mais
seriez-vous nous dire quelle partie du
cétacé était la plus désirée par les un
homme alors à la laitance B la langue
c'est les joues des les poumons alors
j'éliminerai les poumons parce que ça
doit être non je dirais les joues les
joues ouais les joues non pas les joues
la langue
franchement
on adorait le marsouin et le dauphin
mais ça devait être facile à attraper
alors en politique et notamment ici on
sait que et bien souvent ce nous des
histoires que se fait la petite et la
grande histoire à table et donc on vous
a demandé de réfléchir à une brève de
comptoir
alors Philippe est-ce que vous avez un
souvenir politique autour d'un repas
alors des repas en politique on a
beaucoup mais il y a un repas qui n'est
pas politique et
vous avez comprendre je sais pas si vous
voulez comprendre pourquoi je m'en
souviens encore 12 ans plus tard c'était
un Afghanistan j'étais officier officier
de l'armée française là-bas j'étais
médecin militaire et j'étais
l'anesthésiste réanimateur du bataillon
français qui était engagé contre l'État
libre puis un jour le colonel vient nous
voir nous dit bon on a un chef taliban
qui veut passer de notre côté le
problème c'est qu'il veut se faire
opérer du Rhin et il faut aller
l'examiner dans la pampa et puis et puis
du tirer des informations donc du coup
nous voilà partir en désigne un médecin
donc c'est votre serviteur je vous
montre avec la patrouille on file 3-4
heures de route on arrive chez le chef
taliban et ça commence évidemment par un
repas
et moi je devais être particulièrement
en forme parce que je devais donner le
change mon truc j'étais un médecin de
très haut niveau enfin il fallait alors
fallait lui jouer un grand truc et le
gars nous dit bon bah va commencer par
déjeuner et ils apportent c'était des
c'était des abricots ils apportent des
abricots moi je pensais que on va manger
et puis ils abricots arrivent c'était
assez bon je mange 1 2 3 au bout du 5e
deuxième plat d'abricot j'ai bon ben on
va voilà on était on était sur une de
l'herbe par terre je me souviens on
était tous répartis et les armes qui
étaient posées j'ai des photos qui me
reviennent très bien là-dessus et moi je
vois tout le monde qui ment alors je
mange je lui dis bah c'est le repas puis
arrivé au bout d'une heure ou je pensais
que le repas était fini on allait passer
aux choses sérieuses c'est-à-dire la
médecine arrive les plats et là en fait
j'ai 12 ans plus tard encore se souvenir
de ce repas épouvantable parce que
j'avais le ventre qui gonflait gonflait
gonflait puis il a failli à loger
d'aller se lever pour examiner le gars
qui lui était en pleine forme et moi
j'étais lourd j'avais les idées
évidemment vous imaginez les Brico après
les abricots il y a eu des galettes il y
a eu de la durite
tout ça était très lourd
il n'y avait pas de vin mais il y avait
des choses très longues et ce repas
m'est resté comme une sorte de cauchemar
ou je ne voyais plus les choses les
choses je ne savais pas comment j'allais
m'en sortir et puis finalement on a
examiné le gars on l'a opéré et
votre état
on l'a ramené au camp et moi j'étais la
nécessité à part je l'ai endormi je vais
même réveillé je crois donc c'était
plutôt bien et il a donné aux Français
des renseignements donc c'est un repas
patriotique qui a servi à la cause de
l'armée française mais je m'en souviens
encore que 12 ans plus tard belle
histoire en tout cas on va parler à
présent des effets de l'alimentation sur
notre santé et plus précisément des
pesticides utilisés dans nos cultures et
nos récoltes conventionnelles c'est le
dessous des plats
parce que l'exposition aux pesticides
entraîne des maladies graves en 2016
Christian Jouault qui est exploitant
agricole à noisvoutou près de Rennes
développe un cancer de la prostate
reconnu 4 ans plus tard comme maladie
professionnelle par la justice le lien
est établi mais le chemin reste encore
long vers la reconnaissance d'autres
pathologies Hélène Bonduelle est
Baptiste garguichartier
il est ancien éleveur et cultivateur de
maïs Christian Jouault exercer cette
activité depuis plus de 40 ans dans
cette commune nicher au cœur de la
Bretagne l'homme est dorénavant la
retraite mais malgré lui donc c'est là
que autrefois j'ai sévi avec les
pesticides et puis que
et ben que je me suis rendu malade quoi
la nouvelle est tombée en 2016 ce
jour-là les médecins lui diagnostiquent
un cancer de la prostate je me rappelle
plusieurs fois torse nu sur le tracteur
le pulvé derrière je voyais bien que
j'avais du mal à respirer quand même
c'était assez désagréable ou je pensais
pas que le contact avec
par la respiration c'était dangereux un
métier qu'il pratiquait à raison de 10
heures par jour à 68 ans fini la vie
d'avant lui doit vivre avec son cancer
qui récidive un combat permanent dit-il
quand je suis tombé malade j'avais pas
l'intention d'arrêter tout de suite donc
je voulais continuer à exploiter un peu
la ferme mais bon là il a fallu s'en
allait évident c'était pas possible
j'étais surtout en radiothérapie je me
rappelle c'est tellement brûlé enfin
c'était abominable je passais du temps
après une heure ou deux dans la dans la
baignoire pour me refroidir un peu après
je j'allais dormir et puis j'attendais
je vais me reposais jusqu'à ce que le
véhicule vient de me chercher pour les
séances du lendemain quoi mais il n'est
pas le seul à quelques kilomètres de là
collectif créé en 2015 déjà 450 membres
tous ont le même objectif
notre action c'est accompagné des gens
qui sont dans le cadre ou d'étapes des
tableaux de maladies professionnelles ou
par encore comme le papa de Valérie
c'est pas dans les tableaux Christian
quand on a démarré le cancer de la
prostate ce n'était pas dans les
tableaux être dans les tableaux c'est la
reconnaissance de la maladie
professionnelle en ligne de mire une
rentabilités de la maladie en règle
générale la procédure jusqu'à
l'obtention de la vente quand tout se
passe bien c'est au minimum un an le
papa de Valérie on est certain que ça va
durer parce que c'est pas dans les
tableaux donc il va falloir que qu'on
conteste qu'on a le tribunal qu'on se
défend quoi mais au-delà de la
réparation le combat de l'association
c'est aussi l'interdiction des
pesticides
Philippe juin est-ce que l'exposition
aux pesticides entraîne nécessairement
des cancers comme celui de Christian
joule cancer de la prostate que les
études sont contradictoires entre l'OMS
l'Agence européenne des produits
chimiques on ne sait plus trop à qui se
fier donc on vous pose la question
pesticides herbicides vous connaissez le
grand débat avec le glyphosate ou des
gens très savants des agences
internationales se disputent pour savoir
si le glyphosate est ou non cancérigène
un coup l'OMS dit probablement un coup
l'organisation mondiale de
l'alimentation dit probablement non donc
on voit que toute la difficulté en
matière environnementale et de santé
environnementale c'est prouver la
relation causale entre un agent et une
maladie c'est très compliqué parce que
ce monsieur alors ça a été reconnu je
connais pas le de ces monsieur mais on
peut imaginer comme maladie
professionnelle donc je veux dire
des qualités de la justice ce que je
veux dire c'est que bon chez lui on ne
connaît pas le dossier de fond regardez
précisément mais c'est vrai que vous
imaginez imaginez que je sois je suis un
fumeur
alcoolique et je suis exposé à un agent
pathogène est-ce que le cancer que je
vais développer par exemple du poumon
est lié à mon alcoolisme et liée à mon
tabac est lié à l'agent
exogène donc tout ça pour vous illustrer
cette idée que il ne faut pas croire que
c'est facile claque de prouver la
relation de cause à effet entre un agent
potentiellement vulnérant et une
pathologie vous reprenez quoi l'Agence
européenne des produits chimiques la FAO
je ne sais pas parce qu'aujourd'hui
celui qui vous assure que oui ça allait
absolument cancérigène ou qui vous
assure le contraire en disant non ça
n'est absolument pas la probabilité elle
est possible il y a une possibilité mais
il y a pas de certitude il faut la
science
c'est la culture du doute Bachelard
disait
Gaston Bachelard qui est philosophe des
sciences disait
les sciences ça apprend à penser contre
son propre cerveau vous avez une idée
préconçue et bien la science va vous
apprendre à éventuellement la remettre
en cause la question du doute est
fondamentale et j'en suis aux citations
lui pasteur disait le scientifique doit
avoir une qualité principale de qualité
c'est le doute méticuleux les deux mots
sont importants le doute je prends pas
comme argent comptant le fait que parce
que j'ai vu ça il y a ça et méticuleux
parce que je vais méticuleusement
essayer de décrypter le mécanisme et
donc je ne sais pas répondre à votre
question d'ailleurs personne honnête
de précaution le principe de précaution
donc vous vous êtes pour ce principe et
vous dites bon bah dans ces cas-là on
l'arrête quand j'étais député européen
j'ai voté pour la raie
je pense qu'il faut qu'on ait aussi
l'intelligence de continuer à lire les
études qui sortent éventuellement si les
études contredisaient l'idée qu'on
pouvait en avoir quelques années revenir
même si pour des raisons sociétales
bonne chance au ministre qui va décider
ça mais il faut pas que le il faut pas
que le principe de précaution devienne
un principe qui interdise tout parce que
soit on veut un risque zéro il y en a
pas de risque zéro soit parce qu'au
moindre doute on s'arrête qu'est-ce que
vous diriez d'une invention demain il y
a une invention qui change complètement
la vie des gens qui sauvent des vies
mais qui tuent pas moi 1000 personnes
par an en France est-ce qu'on l'adopte
ou pas ça s'appelle la voiture le
principe de précaution est-ce qu'on
interdit la voiture et voilà et en fait
le sujet là c'est le bénéfice risque
donc vous allez me dire où elle bénéfice
du glyphosate ben justement ça s'étudie
on peut imaginer qu'il y a bénéfice
de lutter contre la famille
tous ces sujets sont à prendre en compte
donc je suis désolé de pas vous répondre
oui absolument ou non absolument parce
que je ne sais pas et parce que encore
une fois la science ne permet pas
aujourd'hui de l'affirmer contrairement
à ce que des ayatollahs pour ou contre
veulent vous dire vous n'allez pas
changer la vie vous êtes contre la
ré-autorisation du glyphosate puisque
l'Union européenne va devoir décider là
en 2023
il faut lire les derniers papiers qui
sont sortis il faut avoir le doute
méticuleux il faut être sérieux
c'est-à-dire que là la science l'action
politique doit être évidemment et
évidemment
guidé par la science et mais la science
c'est pas j'ai lu une manchette du
journal Le Monde et je sais ce qu'il y a
dedans je lis les papiers complètement
je lis les matériels et méthodes je lis
les biais des études parce que dans
beaucoup d'études vous avez des biais
c'est pas parce qu'il y a des billets
dans une étude qu'elle est mauvaise
intrinsèquement il y a des biais dans
des études en fait la crise du covid a
un peu bouleversé les Français qui ont
voulu absolument avoir des réponses
définitives à des questions d'ordre
scientifiques et ils ont découvert que
les scientifiques passaient leur temps à
douter et c'est pour eux ça a été une
découverte épouvantable parce qu'ils
espérait avoir des vérités définitives
là où souvent nous avons des questions
ce n'est pas une science exacte la
elle peut arriver à une exactitude
heureusement il y a un moment on arrive
par exemple à montrer que la terre n'est
pas plate ça on l'a montré elle est
ronde et bien malgré ça savez-vous et
lui 8% des Français qui considèrent que
encore la terre qui n'exclut pas que la
terre puisse être plate et
particulièrement chez les jeunes donc
quand je tire le fil de dire il y a la
question du doute méticuleux d'un
principe de précaution qu'il faut
utiliser précautionneusement et pas
comme un principe d'interdiction ce qui
est souvent le cas et puis il y a la
question de l'éducation et c'est vrai
que la disparition des sciences dans
l'éducation parce que c'est le cas les
séances disparaissent dans l'éducation
font que bien sûr ça a été montré
partout bon le pizza classement pizza
vous montre comment on allait on est
vraiment les derniers et puis un rapport
du célèbre qui m'a effrayé qui regarde
les mathématiques le calcul pardon en
primaire et bien il y a une partie
importante des professeurs qui ne sont
pas capables de résoudre les problèmes
qu'ils donnent eux-mêmes alors à leurs
élèves pourquoi parce que des
professeurs du primaire sont souvent
embauchés après parcours qui sont plutôt
des parcours littéraires puisque les
parcours mathématiques et donc on a un
sujet majeur là sur l'enseignement des
sciences il faut réapprendre les
sciences
non seulement parce qu'on a besoin de
scientifiques deuxièmement parce que le
progrès des sociétés le progrès
technique le progrès qui fait qu'on
sauve des vies et qu'on a de la
croissance et du progrès et qu'on résout
la crise climatique par le programme
c'est grâce aux scientifique et puis
troisième point la science comme je vous
l'ai
dit tout à l'heure elle permet de
réfléchir différemment et de faire de
bons citoyens c'est-à-dire des citoyens
qui s'interrogent sur eux-mêmes la
disputation intellectuelle alors
brigitalie pas de lien prouvés en tous
les cas scientifiquement entre le
glyphosate et les cancers chez ces
agriculteurs en revanche des études de
médecins professeur de Montpellier du
CHU de Montpellier avait la fait des
études très précises en montrant la
corrélation entre l'usage de pesticides
et des malformations congénitales
notamment chez les enfants avec des
micro pénis chez des garçons et une
puberté précoce chez les filles là où
vous souvenez de cette étude qui est là
pour le coup
se disait vraiment que l'usage de
pesticides causait des dégâts
épouvantables sur la santé des nouveaux
moi j'affirme que l'environnement a un
rôle très important dans l'émergence
d'un certain nombre de maladies je
l'affirme je répondais à votre question
précise sur le glyphosate parce que
c'est vrai qu'il y a une discussion
et je vais vous donner un autre exemple
la question des talates les talates ce
sont des produits qu'on utilise dans
notre environnement il y en a sur il y
en a peut-être sur cette table il y a
non il y en a dans les bouteilles d'eau
en plastique etc et les stalates sont
des perturbateurs endocriniens
c'est-à-dire qu'il modifie la manière
qui a le corps de vivre c'est quoi un
perturbateur endocrinien ben vous savez
vous vivez et votre corps sécrète des
substances certaines sont appelées des
hormones et ces hormones elles vous
permettent ou des neurotransmetteurs
vous permettent d'avoir des enfants de
grandir d'être en forme etc et d'avoir
le cœur qui s'adapte à un effort et bien
ces médicaments ces médicaments ces
produits probablement modifient le
fonctionnement de votre corps et donc à
long terme ont des effets et il a été
assez bien montré qu'il y a une chute
très importante de la fertilité mondiale
avec par exemple la qualité du sperme ça
a été montré c'est -35 ou moins 40 % de
qualité de reproduction du sperme à
l'échelon mondial donc on n'est pas
seulement en France donc c'est un
problème mondial parce que il y a
probablement des salades désormais
partout donc la question
environnementale
le plastique en fait de des biberons
avec laquelle c'était fait mais alors
vous voyez la conséquence de tout ça
cette observation c'est un il faut
affirmer le rôle de l'environnement dans
l'émergence des maladies et en même
temps certains disent ah bah oui alors
c'est terrible la chimie a produit tout
ça c'est des saloperies il faut revenir
à l'âge de pierre parce que avant au
moins bon sauf que on ne se sortira de
tous les problèmes qu'on a nous-mêmes
créés mais aussi de problèmes qui sont
des problèmes naturels la mortalité liée
au virus plus aux bactéries le
réchauffement climatique on en sortira
que par le progrès scientifique donc le
progrès scientifique n'est pas l'ennemi
souvent ceux qui vous disent
l'environnement a créé des maladies vous
disent donc le progrès c'est mauvais non
le progrès c'est la solution qui va nous
permettre de trouver des solutions
de la recherche à tous ces sujets donc
il faut accentuer la recherche alors on
va parler on va revenir à l'alimentation
et on va parler de l'hôpital qui n'est
pas toujours réputé pour sa cantine vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure on y mange
trop souvent mal difficile alors pour
les malades de retrouver l'envie de se
mettre à table on en parle et on met les
pieds dans le plat
oui Brigitte comment redonner de
l'appétit à des malades au traitement
lourd comment les réconcilier avec la
gourmandise c'est le défi de Christian
tête d'oie c'est un chef étoilé lyonnais
qui supervise notamment les menus du
centre anti-cancéreux Léon Bérard et
vous allez le voir ça marche c'est un
reportage à Lyon de Mathieu préaux et de
maïtéremont
et par dessus donc un petit sauté de
volaille aux champignons
ce matin-là Christian tête doit chef
étoilé mais une touche finale à son menu
du jour sous le regard d'un autre chef
en tout cas ça sent bon ensemble il
décide de redonner du goût à la
nourriture de l'hôpital car depuis 6 ans
deux fois par mois Christian tête doit
s'installe au fourneau de cette cuisine
un peu particulière celle d'un hôpital
de Lyon un centre qui lutte contre le
cancer dans toutes les réunions qu'on a
fait avec les patients et les patientes
beaucoup disent que ils préfèrent manger
froid
donc même l'été un plat comme ça tu peux
le manger froid
un peu ici 1200 repas sont servis chaque
jour le chef de l'hôpital a fait appel
au savoir-faire de Christian tête doigts
pour revoir la carte entière avec un
budget à respecter 5 euros 40 par
passion on essaye de travailler le
maximum de produits frais mais là encore
c'est pas facile suivant les saisons
suivant les prix on arrive pas toujours
mais
c'est ce qui fait le charme peut-être
c'est de réussir à faire des petits
miracles ici au total 387 recettes ont
été élaborées toutes à la texture
différente
on s'adapte à chaque demande chaque
demande ici on avait une nuggets là on a
les carottes et des pâtes avec une
omelette ici c'est à la carte le patient
choisi parmi plusieurs menus en fonction
de son appétit et de ses envies bonjour
vous désirez un plateau car l'objectif
est bien là redonner aux 300 malades qui
viennent se soigner le plaisir de manger
on perd un peu le goût déjà on n'a pas
toujours la possibilité chez soi de bien
bien manger parce que si comme moi les
seuls c'est compliqué de faire de la
cuisine de et là je trouve que c'est
très bien ça donne des idées en fait
aujourd'hui la chimiothérapie et les
médicaments provoquent une altération de
goût et des difficultés de déglutition
la problématique chez les patients qui
ont un cancer c'est que la dénutrition a
une prévalence très importante on sait
que jusqu'à presque 40% des patients
sont à risque sont dénutri à l'hôpital
ou sur les hauteurs de Lyon dans son
restaurant Christian tête doit devenu
cuisinier solidaire de l'année continue
devrait pour les malades après des
sprays parfumés sa dernière invention
ces sauces congelées plus riches qui
permettent une prise de poids de 33% en
seulement un mois
alors vous connaissez cette initiative
vous êtes bluffé par ce chef qui donne
de son temps pour aller nourrir donner
de l'appétit donner de l'envie de manger
aux malades et puis au Seigneur qu'on a
pas vu dans le reportage mais qui sont
aussi Brigitte très touchés par la
dénutrition ah mais je trouve ça
formidable ce qui est la preuve que
quand vous donnez aux gens la
possibilité d'exprimer
librement leur potentialité leur génie
en fait ça marche une autre pays souffre
justement de toutes ces normes qui
empêchent des initiatives c'est
absolument formidable parce que à
l'hôpital
quand oppose la question aux gens il y a
des enquêtes qui ont été faites au point
mondiales qu'est-ce qui vous a le plus
marqué vous avez été hospitalisé et donc
les gens classe
est-ce que la chambre était propre
est-ce qu'on m'a dit bonjour est-ce que
j'ai bien mangé la qualité du Soi
lui-même arrive après je suis pas en
train de nous dire c'est pas important
mais donc c'est fondamental quand même
mais bien manger c'est déjà mangé
pourquoi parce que il y a la question du
coup il a raison il en a parlé il faut
qu'il y a du goût il faut que les gens
trouvent un plaisir alors ça c'est la
réalité de ce que vous voyez vous à
l'hôpital ils sont comment les repartent
il y a plusieurs choses il y a le repas
lui-même qui est très inégal c'est pas
il faut que le gars il vienne voilà il
faut qu'il pleut le jour à l'hôpital
Pompidou moi je suis pas le directeur de
l'hôpital mais s'il veut venir il est
bienvenu et je lui faciliterai la tâche
mais il y a aussi la logistique je
reconnais l'histoire moi mon père qui
était très malade qui est aujourd'hui
malheureusement décédé qui avait une
maladie neurodégénérative qui ne pouvait
plus manger tout seul il est hospitalisé
dans un hôpital parisien je vais pas
vous dire lequel et j'arrive pour le
voir et l'infirmière me dit dans le
couloir il n'a pas voulu manger j'entre
en fait mon père qui n'était pas capable
de manger il fallait l'aider c'est pas
qu'il voulait pas manger le truc était
encore sous blister
était ouvert donc en fait on lui avait
pas donné à manger et donc la priorité
des priorités à l'hôpital c'est vrai
c'est la qualité vous avez raison il
faut que c'est du goût mais c'est aussi
la possibilité technique de prendre un
repas dans un dans une EHPAD parce que
l'hôpital vous irez du jour dans je n'ai
pas de vous y restez à vie dans une
EHPAD quand vous avez des troubles de la
déglutition d'Alzheimer en particulier
quand ils avalent ils s'étouffent une
fois sur deux donc vous devez donner à
manger aux gens avec extrême précaution
et prendre du temps il faut une
demi-heure
faut une heure à chaque fois il tousse
il faut une heure pour que les gens
mangent et comment voulez-vous être
soignante qu'à 7 ou 8 personnes à faire
manger il y a une heure pour 7 ou 8
personnes elle n'a pas le temps d'en
comprendre qu'est-ce qui se passe on
leur donne pas on leur donne mal à
manger il se dénutrit et c'est pour ça
que vous trouvez sur l'étape d'epad et
même parfois à l'hôpital un peu parlé
des compléments alimentaires hyper
nutritifs qui sont une sorte de dopant
la question
oui moi quand je mourrais je voudrais
qu'on me tienne la main je pense que il
y a la qualité des soins et puis il y a
je voudrais qu'on tienne la main et
qu'on prenne soin de moi l'alimentation
fait partie et c'est vraiment le parent
pauvre
5,40 c'est ce qui nous a dit c'est un
miracle 5,40 je sais pas comment il fait
pour trouver du goût et des choses qui
changent tous les jours avec 5,40 il
s'était battu ce chef dès 2020 pour
faire une pour qu'il y a une loi pour
qu'on augmente le budget alimentation
des malades dans les hôpitaux vous êtes
pour mais il a raison
mais prenons les choses au début les
choses au début c'est que l'alimentation
en France la production agricole est
devenue très cher parce que les
agriculteurs sont submergés
d'interdiction de normes de machin du
truc qui rend tout ça très coûteux et
nous avons en France j'ai vu un papier
qui l'affirmait je n'ai pas vérifié mais
ça journal très sérieux qui disait que
le coût de l'alimentation est le plus
cher en france rapportait au pouvoir
d'achat
de toute l'Europe on a une on avait une
agriculture qui qui nous assurait une
sodomie alimentaire
deuxièmement aujourd'hui c'est plus le
cas puisque vous savez que la moitié par
exemple des fruits et légumes sont
importés mais en plus ce qui est produit
en français cher et donc les gens ne
peuvent pas se l'acheter donc on a un
problème majeur à la fois sur pattant la
qualité mais le coût à cause de la
surnomes norme trop
les fournisseurs et les distributeurs
vous vous dites non c'est pas le
problème la faute c'est la norme EN
FRANCE
c'est la norme c'est Bruxelles alors la
norme elle est souvent française
malheureusement c'est 100 milliards
c'est 100 milliards
l'hypernormes françaises la spécificité
française de la norme au-delà de la
norme européenne c'est 100 milliards
d'euros qui qui plombe l'économie
française
l'industrie bien entendu mais
l'agriculture aussi vous dites c'est
Bruxelles alors là j'ai été 10 ans
député européen j'ai appris une chose
c'est que nos mots maux français ils
sont français ils sont pas européens
avec les mêmes règles européennes les
Allemands ils n'ont pas ces sujets les
Danois ils n'ont pas ces sujets les
Espagnols n'ont pas ces sujets nous on
les a ça montre bien que en fait nous
les spécialistes français on veut un
exemple concret d'une norme qui par
exemple fait que le prix des aliments en
France est plus cher qu'en Espagne et
bien il y a un insecticide ou un
pesticide je ne sais plus qu'on met sur
les cerises
qui
commet sur les risques qui est interdit
en France alors qu'il est autorisé par
l'Europe et donc les Espagnols et les
Portugais lui l'utilisent donc le coût
de la production des cerises est moins
important que nous et les plus
importantes on apporte les cerises
deuxième exemple nous étions pesticides
c'est pas n'importe quoi c'est peut-être
un principe de précaution ils n'ont pas
une énorme mais c'est toute la question
c'est toute la question c'est quand même
incroyable pourquoi nous avons nous un
principe de précaution qui n'est pas
celui des Espagnols et portugaise après
tout c'est l'Europe on a un même
standard même standing vous voyez
d'exigence les Français se rajoutent des
poids dans leur sac à dos évidemment
c'est plus lourd de porter un sac à dos
rempli de Pierre qu'un sac à dos non
rempli de Pierre les pommes nous étions
le premier producteur mondial le premier
producteur mondial de pomme nous ne
sommes plus aujourd'hui attends c'est la
Pologne pourquoi vous avez sans doute
entendu parler de cette norme débile à
une époque où on vous a expliqué que
pour monter au-delà de trois sur un
escabeau de la 3 marches il fallait
quasiment être attaché ou une
autorisation particulière et c'est vrai
que pour que cueillir une femme en haut
d'un pommier il faut plutôt monter des
marches et tout ça fait qu'aujourd'hui
l'agriculture française meurt de cette
hyper normalisation française rajoutée à
la norme européenne et pour qu'elle ne
meurt pas elle coûte plus cher parce
qu'il faut qu'elle s'adapte les
agriculteurs ils font ce qu'ils peuvent
et bien tout ça dans votre assiette ça
coûte plus cher c'est moins bon pour
revenir sur l'alimentation à l'hôpital
est-ce qu'il faudrait que l'État
subventionne est-ce qu'il faudrait que
l'État aide plus massivement à la fois à
mieux manger ou en achetant du bio par
exemple ce qui aiderait aussi la filière
ou pourquoi pas on engageant davantage
d'infirmières de personnel pour faire
manger les patients comme vous notiez il
y a deux choses d'abord je pense que
l'État il doit avant de subventionner il
doit déjà
relâcher
sa gang dirigiste ce sont les normes
dont je vous parlais nous sommes le pays
des droits de l'homme et nous sommes en
même temps le pays le l'hyper contrôle
administratif donc laissez les
agriculteurs travailler
ce sont les emmerder et vous allez voir
ils vont produire plus mieux et moins
cher et là pour le coup dans l'assiette
ça sera plus facile y compris à
l'hôpital quant à la question de
l'hôpital et des EHPAD
alors on est devant nous une salade de
fruits c'est une sans doute une
interprétation de chez Françoise parce
que Philippe Juvin lui avait demandé des
fruits absolument de simples fruits pas
de pâtisserie genre Saint-Honoré ou
Paris-Brest donc juste des fruits bruts
car ça c'est encore un peu votre côté
hôpital à force de voir les plateaux
repas rikiki avec pure et jambon compote
et pommes des patients vous avez oublié
qu'il existe des vrais desserts philippe
Juvin et je préfère les fruits d'abord
parce que je pense salade de fruits
c'est un peu différent je veux pas être
les agréable vous m'invitez donc elle
est formidable mais c'est vrai que quand
j'avais des fruits c'était des fruits et
comme ça brut une pomme une au revoir
une orange un abricot peut-être un
abricot le moins possible et d'abord
parce que c'est simple pour la c'est
simple
ça permet de faire en sorte que vous
n'avez plus le sentiment de satiété est
obtenu voilà quoi quand vous avez faim
vous avez pas envie de grossir on va
manger des pommes vous allez voir au
bout de une pomme ou deux vous avez
moins faim
avec des feuilles et les oranges la
clémentine d'orange moi j'avoue que je
pourrais en manger beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup elle cédrat je sais pas ce que
c'est le cédrat pour un corsis c'est
agrume entre le citron le pamplemousse
et l'orange mais oui mais on mange juste
les zestes
pour moi j'aime bien le oui les orangers
et puis en plus quand vous allez encore
y compris au mois de décembre vous avez
vous avez ces orangers qui sont là c'est
beau c'est beau en fait dans la commune
dans laquelle j'ai été maire à La
Garenne-Colombes dans les Hauts-de-Seine
qui est évidemment la plus belle commune
de la région parisienne il y a pas
d'orangers mais dans chaque square j'ai
mis en place et maintenant quelques
années quelque chose j'en suis très fier
j'ai mis en place un plan arbre fruitier
c'est à dire que dans chaque square il
doit y avoir alors on avait fait Alice
un poirier un pommier à cerisier etc etc
pourquoi parce que je voudrais que les
enfants qui vont à l'école et qui sont
jamais à la campagne
la compote de pommes qu'ils achètent au
supermarché elle vient d'un arbre et pas
d'une usine voilà donc le plan fruitier
La Garenne-Colombes c'est une réussite
j'en suis assez fière et Philippe givin
d'avoir été notre invité dans politique
à table merci à vous tous de nous avoir
suivis rendez-vous la semaine prochaine
pour un nouveau numéro de politique à
table sur LCP